let's talk about uh feeling good and
confident and successes right like that
white killed me baby so so we got the
media spiraling out of control
sad and desperate did you see that there
was there was the ratings for msnbc on
sunday
they get like 29 000 even i'm crushing
msnbc in the key demos dude
bro it's not it's not fair to say you're
crushing them when they're getting 29
000 viewers no i am definitely crushing
them
i am crushing network news period end of
story that's what i told my mom
now now i'll i'll be fair uh during like
weeknights like rachel maddow gets 3
million
but in the key demo she's getting like
200 000. the key demo being 25 to 55
men with money basically old people are
watching mad
and tucker but tucker's still getting
twice what cnn
msnbc are getting so anyway look i watch
the media's collapse
and i'm laughing because we're growing
and maybe we won't ever be as big as cnn
was
but it's decentralized these days but
there we go we got something else we got
this big big news
from donald trump himself do it trump
files a class action lawsuit against
facebook twitter and google for
censoring him
demands an end to big text silencing and
blacklisting of conservative voices
and calls for punitive damages for
cancel culture victims
he is also suing the ceos of these
companies
i mean that's it now he made his
appearance he was in new jersey
boy did that man look orange very orange
man right there
but hey this is good news now a lot of
people on the left a lot of democrats
are saying
it's doomed to fail there's no way his
suit will succeed
that's not relevant maybe that's true
that's not relevant
how do you win a fight if you never
fight it
you stand there watching somebody poke
and prod and bully and oppress
and you say there's no point in fighting
because we'll lose imagine
imagine this it's like a bug's life you
know was it with the crickets
yeah was that what was it was the
crickets versus i didn't see it
grasshoppers grasshoppers
there you go the grasshoppers are like
they outnumber us a thousand to one if
they find out the system like they're
going to topple us
everybody loves using that analogy the
left and the right but but think about
it right now
if you're watching these grasshoppers
kick people around these billionaires
these tech oligarchs
push people around and you're like we'll
never win against them
there's no point in fighting
congratulations you're right
whether whether you uh what is it what
is this saying whether you believe you
will succeed or you will fail you're
right yep
you're right now what happens if every
single person who got banned said i'm
filing a suit
i'll probably lose but i'm gonna file a
suit anyway imagine if a million people
filed lawsuits against facebook they
would be they would be buried in legend
in litigation so there was actually i
can't remember if it was patreon or a
couple
or the ones where they had an automatic
arbitration clause
so anytime anybody filed a complaint
they automatically had to go to
arbitration it was paid for by patreon
yep so i remember guys like box day and
others were like
really rallying people to try to take
advantage of this
the thing about trump that people loved
and loved to this day
is that dude is a fighter okay he will
fight
that he's not going to take it he's
going to fight he made a lot of mistakes
though
he could have fought better oh of course
but he's at least trying something
right he's just trying something and you
know the first thing that you do in a
lawsuit like this is you do the
spaghetti thing
you throw the spaghetti up against the
wall you sight all the people
individually all of them personally all
their associates all the different
entities
and then you force the other side into
having to now make arguments as to why
they need to dismiss this guy and
dismiss that guy
they spend money there's discovery it's
all part of
the normal process now i have no idea
the legalities of this will chamberlain
probably be the best person to talk to
about this or ron coleman and those guys
uh who know
you know how these lawsuits are gonna go
but i like the energy fight back
man fight back i obviously colluded
right
right i i've talked to will who's uh
who's very smart he's a lawyer so he
knows a lot about this
and i've brought up a lot of things to
him where he says that's no good that
maybe that's no good and
i don't know maybe a judge will agree
with that one that that
that right there whether or not you get
a judge to agree with you is the biggest
question
did you make a good enough argument to
convince a judge and what i've seen
across the board from defamation
lawsuits to censorship lawsuits
is the lawyers have made really bad
arguments because they fundamentally
don't understand what they're talking
about
no i i mean no disrespect a lot of these
lawyers because some of them have done
good lawsuits that got thrown out
but they don't understand the nature of
the system
they don't understand the attack vectors
i think wikipedia may be one of the
best uh uh um one of the weakest
platforms that could create a hole in in
the whole 230 argument
and defamation specifically so um
tell me i got larry singer coming on
tomorrow wikipedia
when you go to wikipedia.com i love
pulling up james o'keefe let me pull up
james o'keefe on wikipedia
veritas is probably about i'm sure it
says very nice and honest and true
things about about that's exactly the
point
so let me actually james o'keefe's it's
got a lot of bad things in it it's very
it's very it's framed you know kind of
uh
very poorly but actually let me pull up
a project veritas
there we go because project veritas
according wikipedia is a far-right
activist group founded by james o'keefe
it produces deceptively edited videos
undercover operations we've talked about
this a bit
like i like using veritas specifically
because it's all lies
and opinion what is jack what is that
what does this say right here
can you read that from wikipedia the
free encyclopedia
oh it doesn't say from you know mega
megadude 539 it doesn't say from
jack murphy live does it no no this
article is
from wikipedia project free encyclopedia
from wikipedia
so who's responsible for that defamation
i would say wikipedia
i would argue that i'd say so and i
think no one's
uh you need to sue on that grounds james
o'keefe would need to file a lawsuit
against wikipedia for defamation for oh
i'm sorry for libel
and say that wikipedia called us this
uh accuses of deceptively editing videos
now my understanding is
he recently won over the phrase
deceptively edited in the new york times
case yeah
case the case has not concluded yet but
a judge said that uh
actually maybe it wasn't near times one
but i'm pretty sure
he did win a case where he said it
wasn't deceptively edited i could be
wrong though but anyway i digress
i love the way that they've got
citations for far right
and then deceptively edited that's the
way that they're going to get out of it
right they're going to go to go to that
citation we're just citing
i don't think that's a major news source
i think an argument has to be made you
got to go to court you know why
if ian comes to me and says jack murphy
can't do a backflip
and then i go jack murphy can't do a
backflip it's a fact
yeah you told me you're responsible for
that if you did that just because
ian told me and then i go out and say it
and it's a fact doesn't mean the
responsibility doesn't follow on me
anymore
well i'm going to talk to larry sanger
co-founder of of wikipedia tomorrow
on jack murphy live check it out on
youtube maybe it'll uh talk him into
filing suit on behalf
of all these people against his former
company that he started
because i'm pretty sure he's not in
favor oh definitely
what's going on there we've talked to
him about i think we talked to him about
this
yeah we did and i think the big
distinction for wikipedia is that it
says it's from wikipedia yeah you can
put all the citations in the world you
want and say don't look at me i was just
citing this source it's like bro
you said it was from you so so donald
trump is suing all these companies
the the establishment saying he's doomed
to fail the knight foundation
saying he's doomed to fail which is so
insane to me
when did these freedom of the press
defensive little guy
turn into the pro-corporate pro-big tech
non-profits
it was the trump thing man it was trump
it was trump all of a sudden anything
anybody said was bad if you if you
listen to
the media sources you grew up with if
you the people that you trusted
all of a sudden they went ape yeah and
then the public went ape
could you imagine donald trump runs into
a burning building
comes out singed but carrying a box of
puppies and then
vox.com writes why puppies are actually
bad exactly like it's a picture of
donald trump and he's like
his hair's burned off he's just bald and
scarred and he's like orange
but i saved the puppies they're the best
puppies everyone agrees they needed to
live
and they're like actually puppies are a
bad thing baby puppies
they have two there's too many of them
people aren't getting them spayed and
neutered
they spread corona yeah this puppy looks
like hitler
oh my gosh and trump saved him what does
that say about trump you know my problem
with
with trump kind of what you said earlier
was what people love about him is that
he's a fighter
is that i've known people in my life
that are have like anger issues and
would like get really angry and punch a
wall
and that's like the fighter in them and
it would break the wall or they'd break
their hand and they wouldn't solve the
problem but they just wanted to hit
and fight and i'm worried that trump
just lashes out
like irrationally and has no hope of of
getting them to change their terms of
service i mean what legal bounds would
anyone have to get a private company to
change their terms of service that's
insane that's fascist it's it's
you need to set precedence yeah you need
you need to do you would so trump files
a lawsuit but it's spaghetti on the wall
the judge says it's a fiscal you know uh
the the
the the allegations one through a
hundred are all bad but 101 102 and 103
are good
bring us back an argument around those
that's how it goes
yeah i don't know i don't think that's
that that's what happened to my kids
with defamation they had like 33 claims
the judge threw out 30 of them they were
kept three and then the companies
settled because they were scared of
discovery now i'll tell you what's
really interesting about this lawsuit
with trump
there are actually a bunch of people on
the left that are are saying trump
uh that these companies should not get
these cases dismissed you know why
they want facebook and twitter to uh
agree basically let the suit happen and
then move to discovery
subpoena trump get him under oath get
his his emails get his documents
around january 6th trump is saying i was
banned on this day for these reasons and
i'm suing
twitter and facebook could be like okay
let's get your emails on that day and
see what you were saying to prove
whether or not
you had the intention that we thought
you did and then
they get trump's emails i guess we'll
see if that's actually
the uh a flaw in their strategy as they
push forward with the lawsuit i have to
suspect
it's just the the the optimist in me
that
somebody on trump's team might have
suggested that that would be an
outcome or it's actually really simple
maybe trump didn't actually do any of
the things they accuse them of doing
of course yes and so trump's last step i
don't care yeah
yeah i think we know what trump's emails
are going to look like
i think do you there it's going to be
really like
short yeah lazy does he even say didn't
he say he doesn't send emails
yeah smart i mean it is wise why put
anything in writing you know
you know when you're talking to somebody
who's been a little bit paranoid is when
you're texting
and then all of a sudden you get an
audio of an audio message that's exactly
is that a text that's all i do is i send
audio messages
i leave everything out of text unless it
is 100 necessary
30 30 second audio clips to say what i
got to say that's it
if you can keep those and share those
maybe fine you're really putting an
extra effort for that then
i guess i guess audio is better at least
there's context
like you can hear my tone of voice yeah
yeah
text twitter doesn't work at all like
and i think
this i don't know if i'm just biased
maybe that's the case
but people on the left man they really
really have a hard time
they have a really hard time so like
shuan had tweeted something as a joke
sarcastically
about you know i don't know fascism or
something and then i responded with
so you admit it that's like i love
tweeting at people so you admit it
to like it the joke is i'm taking what
they
say out of context to apply it's literal
and it's a joke
the people who follow me totally get
that that is a joke
but uh vosh tweeted tweeted about uh so
china
just uh well i don't i don't know about
china specifically but wechat
banned lgbtq accounts tons of them wiped
it out wiped out all this content
and vosh tweeted this is the right move
in furtherance of glorious communism
long live president xi jinping
obviously he's not being serious so you
admit it eh that's what i said
so i tweeted so you admit it and then
immediately i knew i had to do this i
replied with
in before anyone thinks either of these
tweets are real right i knew he was
joking
like he's not praising she's making a
joke and then i responded with the joke
obviously bro so many people were just
like you're so
dumb like why she's mad he's not serious
so imagine imagine if these people who
are that dumb
i'm sorry family are your actual family
your actual
mom or your sister or your cousin no
exactly who are reading your tweets
and taking all the jokes seriously
and none of the serious stuff seriously
i'm like you guys just have to stop
reading just stop
reading my social media because they
think they think that the stuff that is
specifically
trolly that is meant to push people away
that is if you're in on it is obviously
a joke
and if you're not in on it good go away
they're part of the good go away crowd
and they're like oh my god
what's happened to you oh we don't even
know you anymore you're a monster
did a bunch of people like just eat a
brick of fluoride or something
something happened where there's like
people who don't understand jokes
anymore
that's that's dude but listen it's not
about just understanding jokes there are
people who can't differentiate
fact from fiction so there's like people
like
us where we're kind of skeptical in a
lot of ways we're well researched
not geniuses not no we don't know
everything we're wrong a lot
sure jack just you're the best no that's
ian i'm talking about jack's
genius so so i can be like
here's what i think based on this right
i can have a conversation like let's
let's say i'll have a a debate
or a discussion with like a leftist
personality and i'll say something like
when it comes to universal healthcare
you have an argument between
utilitarianism and
deontological philosophy and he goes i
don't know what that is
and we try to explain it to them and
then maybe i'll be like okay i gotta
dumb it down
for you so maybe i'll use a movie
reference because you're clearly not at
the same level but i'm trying to
communicate and then they'll start
laughing being like duh he said marvel
he's so dumb how do you like you you
have these people
that hear brian selter go donald trump
is working for russia or something like
that
and then you get chris hayes where you
got jonathan saying trump may have been
a russian assets in the 1980s and they
go
whoa and then the mueller report comes
out it's all not true and they go
whoa and then rachel maddow comes out
and says russia again and they go
whoa tucker carlson russia
and then meanwhile people like us on
this side whatever are going like
well something's not right you can't
just say both things like which one's
true which one isn't
but i i i seriously think when you look
at the democratic establishment
these are people who either lying many
of them probably are or just too
dumb to like actually do any of the work
it's definitely both
i mean i think it's both look at uh uh
um
i think ethan klein is a really good
example because what started the feud
with him and stephen crowder is when he
said
bro you don't even got to do any
research just like it's on the cdc you
know what i mean yeah
the kind of people who would be like i
have no responsibility
and i don't care that they're going to
go and be like i don't know dude cnn
just said i don't want to do anything
like
why do i have to do work i think that's
that's an example of ethan
maybe dumps out the right word but
ignorant he'll talk about things he
doesn't know about like what he just did
about the cdc
um just don't even think about it that
comment but he's he will also lie
for for comic value like just to have
fun with someone so it's both
do you think like so when he said just
trust the cdc it's easy
do you think if i said to ethan klein yo
bro the tuskegee experiments
you know his answer is going to be i
don't know what that is he's like they
didn't make peanuts
yeah what that's just a joke anyway you
remember what you said
getting things confused with johnny
carter and then the peanut guy and then
the other guy he was a peanut farmer
jimmy carter he was now listen
i think what we're seeing revealed by
the left is their lack of sense making
and they don't have a sense making life
cycle
so they don't actually have built into
them some way of
of understanding and sifting through all
the information to come to the right
idea
so they they have this they've sort of
um uh
uh um uh dis this circuited is that
associated or
uncircuited is that a word circuited
dissociated
no no they they've stripped out the
circuitry for sense making they haven't
like adopted this new skill which we all
have which is
you hear it here you hear it there you
go over here you look over there you
listen to 12 different people
experts all of them plus your friend and
your cousin you put it all together
and with actual research and independent
opinions from people from all across the
spectrum
you come to a conclusion yes now that
and that's a process
sense making is a process that comes
through dialogue
and conversation and experimentation
these people on the left are revealing
they have no sense making skills
right they just say thing and they just
move on from the thing they say a thing
they move
on from the thing they haven't developed
the ability to figure out what's
actually real
you need to kind of remove your emotions
from the situation
you're gonna come to it with humility
yeah you're gonna be wrong you're gonna
find out the things you thought were
real aren't real a lot of times and
that's why when we teach sense making in
the liberal order one of the things that
we really focus on are you hungry
are you angry are you lonely are you
tired right now
because this is going to affect the way
that you process this information that
you're receiving
have you ever actually thought about any
of those feelings even a lot of people
no no like a lot of people will just be
like they'll go to the fridge and
they're and they'll eat
and no one's ever stopped them and said
are you hungry right now right and
they'll go
no i'm just bored i've been thinking a
lot about anger lately and like what
causes anger a lot of times it's
sadness or uh madness
and what causes madness if you're not
being listened to if you feel like
you're not being seen you can become mad
and then if
that's untended then you can become
angry anger's the worst i mean i think
anger's like the worst
worst mind state you can be in you know
you know what they say there's there's
two things there's two bits of advice
one's family-friendly and one's not
family-friendly
the first bit of advice is eat before
you go grocery shopping right definitely
because people go in there and like ice
cream ice cream my screen
and it's like you go home and you're
like bro i can't eat it olive oil
i just wanted bananas i just wanted the
ice cream right now so that's all i want
no you're like you eat a good meal go to
the store and then you're like i'll get
a little bit of
the other one is uh less family friendly
but they say before you if you're a dude
before you go on a date you got to go
take care of business
clarity so you get that mental clarity
otherwise start thinking wrong things
right it doesn't always work
remove the sense of urgency yeah we're
talking
about it right get good in the moment
make sure you're not hungry angry lonely
or tired make sure you've squatted
make sure you've slept and then make
sure you bounce all these things off
people
a network of people that you have built
i don't think that these guys on the
left have
have demonstrated any ability to sense
make
or to accelerate their process of
observing
uh understanding making a decision and
taking action or the
loop right observe orient decide and act
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time